now that we've calculated the change of
potential energy between some initial
and final heights for the gravitational
problem mg of y final minus y initial
we've for this conservative force of
gravity and we had our coordinate system
like that we were able to calculate the
change in potential energy and remember
our theorem is that non conservative
work equals Delta K plus Delta u now
what we'd like to do is establish the
concept of a reference point for
potential energy and we'll do that as
follows
see the change in potential energy only
depended on say our initial state and
our final state what we'd like to do is
introduce the concept of a reference
point so let's identify some point YP to
be our reference point and we'll define
a potential YP to be the reference
potential and if we want to talk about
the potential energy in a final state
will always refer it to the reference
between that and the reference point so
this is Delta U between the final state
and the reference point likewise for the
initial state will will always refer
that with respect to our reference point
so any state that we have we can always
refer the potential energy difference
between some state and some reference
point why do we do this because notice
that if we look at you final minus u
reference point and we subtract from
that u initial minus u reference point
then the difference the reference points
here we have a minus here we have a plus
this is just equal to u final minus
initial which is Delta u so the change
in potential energy between any two
states is independent of how we choose
our reference potential but it can make
calculations easier when we can identify
what the potential energy is for a
little state now let's look at our
example so for our gravitational problem
we will choose Y reference point to be 0
and we'll choose the potential energy at
this reference point also to be 0 so our
reference potential at the origin is 0
and I'll denote it like that then the
potential energy at some initial state
minus the reference point well we can
use our formula here because this is
between any two states so this is mg Y
initial minus the reference point but
our reference point was 0 and so we see
that you initial minus y reference point
which was also 0 is just equal to mg Y I
and so we have the statement that the
potential energy difference between our
initial state and the reference point is
just mg where Y I is the height that the
initial state is above the reference
point in a similar way we have u final
is mg y final and so we see we recover
what we expect this is just mg y final
minus y initial
now this we can generalize just a little
bit by saying that for any for let's
write that for us our mass which is it
for any height Y our potential energy
function for the gravitational force U
of Y is equal to mg Y that's a formula
that many of you have seen before but
it's very important to know
that with this formula U of zero equals
zero because that's our reference point
and that becomes our potential energy
function for the gravitational force now
our next step will be to do the same
thing for spring forces and
inverse-square gravitational forces and
we'll also look at graphical analysis of
this function